i'll be back
okay
energy
oh
uh
thank you
remember
is
i'll be right back
okay
um
but
thank you
so
uh
just
um
i'm sure
you got two minutes
how many trackers
uh
hi guys
hmm
well good afternoon everyone uh when the
senate last
acted with regard to coven 19 back in
march and april
we had at that point added about three
trillion dollars
to the national debt uh we then
of course ended up with a debt the size
of our economy for the first time since
world war ii which is in and of itself
concerning so i said i thought we needed
to push the pause button
begin to see the impact of the kara's
act
and related acts that passed her in that
period
see how we did when the economy began to
reopen
and take another look at what the
country
needed in july
we've been we many senate republicans in
the administration
have been consulting over the last few
weeks
to come up with a realistic proposal
with what we think is an appropriate
amount of additional debt to be added
to the economy at this time
we think it is about a trillion dollars
and we've allocated that in a way that
we think makes the most sense
for the country at this particular time
it will include liability insurance
which senator liability
protections which senator cornyn is
going to describe here shortly
but let me just make it clear there
won't be a bill that passes the senate
it doesn't have this in it there have
already been 3 500 lawsuits filed
the country cannot stand an epidemic of
lawsuits on the heels
of the pandemic we're already working
our way
through so with that i'm going to call
my colleagues who have developed the
various
component parts of our proposal and i'm
not
certain who comes second do we know
who's next
number one we're going to continue the
economic impact
payments that were made in april and may
uh that means that the average family of
four will
will get another payment of 3 400
it includes just a few people
that were unintentionally left out
of the last one mostly dependents
college and adults that are somebody
else's dependent
we extend additional unemployment
insurance and remember that's on top of
whatever the different 50 states give
and on top of the economic impact
statement i just
gave so we want to continue to help the
unemployed
but we want to encourage work and we've
learned a very
tough lesson that when you pay people
not to work
what do you expect and so this payment
will be adjusted so that we have
additional payments
to help people for approximately 70
to 75 of their uh
income that's not me
i don't think
well it sounds just like mine
we're going to have further
tax relief for businesses to encourage
hiring and
rehiring and we
we want to do that to encourage people
to get back to work and help the
employer in the process support people
in the meantime
support patients in nursing homes and
and and also foster youth flexibility
and how state local governments can use
federal relief funds including an
ability to use funds to cover
revenue shortfall and if
somebody doesn't want me to get on
television tonight i know that
you got to be kidding why didn't you
tell me that
i'm embarrassed i'm sorry lastly
i hope that democrats will come to the
table and we work out a bipartisan
agreement thank you very much
chairman shelby well we all know this is
uh
round one we believe that
as the leader said as senator grassley
and others will say
this is a this is for the american
people
to help get them back to work keep them
at work
get them back to school keep them in
school as safely as
we can we've already put out a lot of
money these are extort these are
extraordinary times
uh i know the house has has a bigger
figure than this and
and this is something we're gonna have
to work through overall we think this is
a pretty good package and i hope that
the senate in a bipartisan way will move
forward with it
thank you most of the things in our bill
have meaning when added to senator
blunt's appropriations bill so i'll just
speak about
three student loans
school choice and child care
in march congress agreed
that the 43 million americans who have a
student loan
would not have to pay a monthly payment
until october the 1st
the payment would be deferred you'd
still owe it but be deferred
october 1 is just around the corner so
what we propose is
if you have no income you have no
monthly payment
if you do have income then we'll change
the
student loan payment system so that you
never have to pay more than 10
percent of your income after you've
deducted
necessities of life like mortgage and
and food
second on school choice they're about
135 000 public and private schools in
the country thirty five thousand private
schools hundred thousand public
about fifty million children in the
public schools five point
seven in the private schools generally
speaking
we think every child is equally
important
and so what we propose is
about 70 billion dollars for
kindergarten through the 12th grade and
30
more billion dollars for colleges that
amount of money for education is about
the same as the house passed
bill so there could be an area of
agreement
senator blunt will say we believe
that every school should get some money
would be about twelve hundred dollars
per person on k-12 every school should
get a third of that
uh even if they're opening virtually and
the rest of that money
should go to schools that are making an
effort to open as much
as possible with students physically
present there are many more expenses
when you're physically present
buses more teachers more space more
protective equipment
we believe we ought to pay pay for that
on school choice senator scott has a
bill which he will
discuss and i'm a co-sponsor of that
which would
give parents more choices of all schools
and child care child care centers having
a hard time staying open because they
have less revenue
fewer students and there need to be more
safe
environments for child care and finally
we're spending a lot of money to build
up manufacturing base manufacturing
plants
we want to make sure that in the future
they're not in china when we need to
create vaccines
and in the future we want to make sure
we have plenty of mass
and other equipment in our stockpiles so
we authorize that
as well this is a bill about back to
school
back to child care and back to work
the paycheck protection program
has been a lifeline to more than
5 million small businesses
and their employees nationwide
in the state of maine nearly
three-quarters
of all small businesses have received
these forgivable loans that have
sustained the
jobs of 240 000
mainers and brought more than 2.2
billion dollars to the state of maine
we are today proposing a second
round of ppp loans
for the hardest hit small businesses
just this morning i was talking to an
innkeeper in maine
who told me that at this time of year
usually his inn would be booked solid
every single night instead business is
down by
93 so what we are proposing
is that hard hit small businesses
those with revenue losses of 50 percent
or more compared to last year
would be able to receive a second
ppp loan to sustain their employees
and to help cover certain overhead
expenses
another important provision allows
ppp overhead expenses
to be used for renovations
that are necessary to comply with
cdc guidelines personal protective
equipment such as masks or
gloves and other renovations that may be
needed to ensure the safety of both the
employers employees
and customers that will be particularly
helpful
to restaurants for example that are
still
under strict restrictions
there is also a long-term loan
component of the bill that we've
introduced
and senator rubio is going to explain
that
when he gets here i don't think he's
here yet
but arguably this program has been
one of the most successful provisions of
the cares act and i'm delighted
that we are introducing an extension of
it today
thank you
well one thanks mitch for putting us
together last time we didn't do much
about china
this time we are so what have we learned
ninety percent of the protective
equipment that our doctors and nurses
and health care professionals
need to keep us safe and keep their
families safe is made in china
so president trump has hell-bent on
trying to bring the medical supply chain
back
there's a big step forward in this bill
we have a seven and a half billion
dollar
tax credit to incentivize ppe material
to be made
in the united states gloves mass gowns
sanitizers betting
uh seven and a half billion dollar tax
credit modeled off the
energy tax credit we think that'll have
a big effect on
bringing the supply chain back under the
berry amendment there's a requirement
that american military uniforms be made
in america
we're going to put ppe under that so the
national stockpile will have protective
equipment made in america and we don't
have to depend on china
senator cornyn has a chips for america
we lost the semiconductor industry
all left now we're trying to bring it
back taiwan made a big investment in
texas
we're going to give tax credits to make
semiconductors here
which helps you in another way senator
portman's got
a bill that i think is much needed to
punish people who steal
intellectual property in america to
create a security council around
research and development
and penalties for those bad actors who
try to steal their way to success
and finally senator murkowski lives in
alaska
there are a lot of precious critical
medals and materials that america has
but we do a very poor job
of getting it out of the ground in an
environmentally sound way and we're
becoming more and more dependent
on china and other places in the world
for critical minerals
and we've got a plan to to become more
american-made and own there
i think about 25 of the bills in the
labor age education subcommittee about
250
billion dollars none of that money
that's there was there without the input
from chairman shelby and
chairman alexander who chairs the
authorizing committee obviously
chairman shelby chair chairs the full
committee on the education front i think
that's probably been talked about
enough you'll have some questions on
that later on the higher education part
the 30 billion
or so that goes to higher education that
money will go out on an fte
basis to colleges and universities and
we'll go out
quickly we hope and and many of them are
going to reopen as early
as the 10th of august or so so we need
to get that money out
the higher the elementary and secondary
money
the two-thirds being held back for
stu people who are trying to get
in-person education reinstated again
a lot of that money also can go out
quickly under our bill
if at least 50 percent of your students
are
in person 50 percent of the time you
qualify
immediately for the second two-thirds of
the money that would come to your school
and if it's less than that has to be
explained in a different way
left up to governors and the education
department in the state to work on that
on
the health front we have 20 we have 16
billion
new dollars which is a total of 25
billion dollars for testing
our priority to help with testing
through the states
is to put a prior priority on elementary
and secondary education
on higher education on nursing homes and
child care facilities
child care facilities also get a lot of
attention in this bill 15
billion dollars in child care facilities
that frankly have a
work model that doesn't work at 45 and
50 percent which is the likely
child care enrollment as people get back
to work some people don't want to send
their kids
other people will still be looking for
work themselves
and so trying to help get the
numbers and the space to match there'll
be some child care expenses of
distancing and
other things that have to be done but
you can't get back to work if you can't
get back to child care for most families
and if you're a working parent
particularly if you're a working single
parent
your biggest single problem is being
sure that that child care situation
works
we put twice as money in our you know
twice as much money in our bill
uh as the house did in the heroes act
uh and we'll be talking from moving
forward from
that point another 26 billion dollars in
our bill goes to further
advance vaccines therapeutics
particularly vaccines
our hope as you know is to have vaccines
out there
that are out there around the first of
next year
and in doing that we're going to lose
some money because we're going to
move forward with producing some
vaccines we think we'll get full
fda approval that just won't work out
moving forward with the things we think
are likely to work knowing they weren't
all won't all work
but also knowing the ones that do work
will be available maybe january the 15th
instead of may the 15th and in this
environment having a vaccine in january
the 15th
as opposed to may the 15th is worth
billions of dollars and we're willing to
take a chance of use losing some money
to be sure that those vaccines that do
work
are out there earlier
we've got senator collins a big leader
in
being sure we had money for the opioid
abuse that has occurred as people found
themselves isolated at home and maybe
out of work with another problem there
and the mental health issues so we've
got about five billion
on that side of the ledger that would
not be there
in a normal spending year and
there are some hospitals and providers
another 25 billion for them
with a real vigorous discussion with the
administration
that they need to spend all the hospital
provider money they currently have
not spent which is about 65 billion
add that 25 billion to it and then see
how close the providers are to where
they would be
in a normal year you know we ask
hospitals and and
doctors generally providers generally to
do the two hardest things you could do
stop your income and stand ready for the
biggest
health emergency that you can imagine
that your hospital or your practice
would ever have to deal with and that
just doesn't work out very well so
another 25
billion dollars there
what's this about this i'm kidding i um
i think senator collins has already
outlined the new
ppp proposal and let me let me just say
that what you're hearing a lot now in
the small businesses as the ppp money
runs out
is they're beginning to look at new
layoffs which i think is evidence of the
fact that ppp was helpful
the fact that that but at the same time
is also evidence
that we are seeing resurgences in
different parts of the country that are
placing new restrictions
plus the existing restrictions from any
of these businesses is hard to survive
under
and then of course the consumer behavior
is affected by the news of the pandemic
so
it's very timely and in addition to ppp
which is now more targeted
at businesses under 300 with some of the
same parameters but with business under
300 and the revenue demonstration
is something we've seen play out over
the last few weeks and that is that
businesses particularly in underserved
and minority neighborhoods
on average there was a recent study that
said 95 percent of them had less than
two weeks of cash on hand
so you can from that deduce how
difficult it's going to be for many of
them to survive not to mention have
access to regular capital markets in the
future
so so as part of this plan in addition
to ppp there is a
loan targeted at low income
neighborhoods census tracts that are
either in an opportunity zone or
in a new markets tax credit area where
these businesses could get
two times a loan for 20 years at one
percent at two times of their annual
revenue
and these are small companies that would
not be able to otherwise
gain access to that sort of capital that
allows them to survive and grow and
reinvent themselves in in the aftermath
of this pandemic and
what we don't want to see is an unequal
recovery um
and and so for us it was important to
target that
um but i think this assistance will be
timely for small businesses across this
country who are continuing to struggle
many of whom
benefited from ppp and now months into
it are
kind of staring off over the cliff again
and worried about what the future would
hold and i remind everybody once again
this is not a bailout this is about
keeping people attached
to their employment and these are about
viable companies
who are struggling because of government
regulations necessary government
regulations
that are impacting their ability not
just to do business but to stay in
business
thanks senator scott
in the month of april about one out of
every four
americans who lost their jobs worked in
the restaurant business
one of the provisions in the finance
committee on the tax side of this is to
increase the
deduction for meals business meals from
50 percent to 100 percent
that will encourage more folks who spend
more money in restaurants
whether that's take out uh eat in in the
limited space in some states
this will provide millions of dollars
that will increase the number of hours
worked by
the wait staff and the number of hours
worked by those folks working in the
kitchen if we're looking for
a way to help the hardest hit
individuals in this nation one of the
best sectors to focus on
is the restaurant sector and this is
what the provisions
i'm talking about will assist
we'd like to draw attention to one of
the actually two of the consequences of
the kovid crisis that
deserve that attention and perhaps don't
have as much
public awareness as i think they ought
to
one is as a result of the covid crisis
we're seeing the trust funds for
medicare and social security
approach insolvency on a much more rapid
timetable than we'd anticipated
and secondly we're adding up a lot of
debt
we're going to have over 27 trillion
dollars
of debt and that debt requires interest
to be paid every year
that debt has the potential of creating
more inflation down the road
and of course it could lead potentially
to an economic calamity way down the
road for people who come behind us and
as a result republicans and democrats on
a bipartisan basis
have been working together and that
includes senator joe manchin
kirsten sinema angus king doug jones
this is a group of people have come
together and mark warner
along with a about a dozen republican
senators
we've all been working together to see
if we can't address this and in the
house
there are some 30 democrats and 30
republicans that have all
written house leadership and said this
approach of the trust act needs to be
included
in the next coveted relief package in
the heels act if you will
and uh approach is quite simple which is
we we created process
a bipartisan bicameral process to
address each one of these
trust funds individually so a committee
for each one of them to look at how to
make them solvent on a long-term basis
and if we reach a bipartisan conclusion
and bicameral conclusion then that can
come to the floor
on an expedited basis we have to address
the solvency of our trust funds they're
vital to our seniors and to our entire
nation
we also have to finally deal with the
amount of debt that we're adding up
as we rescue appropriately the american
people from this terrible coveted crisis
i'm the last one standing here with the
administration on this legislation
so it was very difficult to negotiate
with the administration to come up with
an agreement you begin negotiations with
the democrats
you were talking about 40 000 as an
income cap in the direct payment
that is not in the legislation so what
else
are you going to have to give the
commission agreement with democrats and
not lose too many republicans and also
why is funding for the fbi building in
this bill
i'm not sure that it is
look i think this is a starting place uh
you can see that we've had a lot of our
members
involved in the start
and we can't pass a bill in the senate
without democrats
nor obviously can it pass the house
so every bill has to start somewhere the
republicans are in the majority in the
senate
this is the starting place and we'll get
you all have plenty of stories to cover
along the way
as we have these discussions back and
forth across party lines and with the
administration
ppp in this bill but it did not discuss
the airline uh the cash
airline employees
still employees i don't have an answer
to the second one
the first one is that we've already
appropriated an awful lot of money for
election assistance
what we're not going to do is federalize
the american election system
which is basically conducted in every
single state
in very different ways we've provided
plenty of financial assistance but we're
not going to
tell them how to conduct their
elections during the pandemic or in my
view
in the future either so that's why
there's not
additional money in there for election
assistance i don't have the answer to
your second question i'm going to take
one more if there is one
uh
obviously we had to have an agreement
with the administration in order to get
started
and they'll have to answer the question
of why they insisted on that provision
you'll have to ask them why they
insisted that be included
okay thank you
so
you